okay so every year my family and I would
go on vacation to North Carolina and
they just grocery store called Harris
Teeter and since last year I started
doing these acquittee O's in this store
and this is the video that I did this
year filmed it and about 15 minutes
running throughout the store and I gotta
go because my parents are yelling at me
hurry up so bye let me don't you think
of the video kids what are you doing
over there
you should be joining me towards ready
to Harris come on
well you could go to Harris Teeter yeah
here we go
Oh see you here are you doin Appetit
all I'm just here to get a gallon feel
so I go to get my
if there's any USDA prime beef on sale
today money goes
Oh
cookies Reynolds Wrap well I think it's
time for me to break it down